my name is Matthew
today to be you recite the comments off
the bang
introduction I hope talking about Conda
a bill dependency management system that
has saved my life several times if you
don't know about it you should be
excited so Travis what up thank you Matt
Wow music am I gonna feel like a rock
star it's great to be here thanks for
coming to visit this talk I know there's
a lot of exciting talks it's tough to
decide which I hope that you won't be
disappointed I'm not really excited and
I talked quite a bit about Conda there's
some jokes actually last time at the
last party of New York we run enough
session and everything every question I
kind of responded to ya Connor does that
the econo does that yet kind of does
that I mean of course there's a lot of
details and a lot of things you may have
to configure to make sure it works but
I'm really excited about Conda because
frankly it solves a lot of problems that
have plagued the scientific Python
ecosystem for decades and they've been
at the heart of a lot of problems that i
personally known about personally been
involved in so I'm really excited about
it because I feel like we finally have a
solution that really takes a lot of pain
away from a lot of other people as well
and we're we're still trying to get the
word out we're still promoting it more
and getting more documentation together
it has a lot of functionality that a lot
of people still aren't necessarily aware
of because it's not necessarily
broadcast as far as wide as it could be
now if you're an anaconda user you
already have Conda although you may not
know of all the features that kind of
can provide for you because that's how
you get the distribution is comments
underlying package manager for the
distributions will talk about but I want
to motivate the discussion a little bit
by talking about the big problem which
everybody is facing we just saw a great
talk from the cheap from this data
scientist uber geeks data geeks at
Facebook showing how many open-source
tools they use then they also contribute
back and not phenomena actually exists
on every company almost every company
out there they're using data science
tools they're using open source tools
and also contributing back what that's
doing is exploding the number of
available tools it's just growing and so
how do you actually use these tools
people want to use these tools they say
hey other people are doing the work that
I otherwise I don't have to spend money
doing I ought to figure out how to deal
with it but it's not about just using it
once it's not about okay I grabbed it I
got this version of numpy in 2007
I'm done no because it's going to change
six months one year year and a half to
the change how you gonna manage that
change process the big challenge is that
a fundamental principle of software
engineering is that separation of
concerns which you want to separate
components and different pieces but you
have to bring it back together and then
sometimes that creates these deep
dependency hierarchies and to end up
with a dependency graph that might look
like this where you've got just
thousands potentially deep of
dependencies in a very large complex
system how do I deal with that in a real
real way so I call entry points kind of
that end user application that end user
script there's a final point which you
use this is what I want to accomplish
for my application or my process and but
I have a lot of dependencies that might
have and those packages themselves might
have dependencies so you end up having
different any different versions the
third problem is one person on a system
a single machine may want one version of
a package their particular dependency
tree requires one version of package
another person on the same system
requires a different dependency tree
different version of another package
this problem is actually not specific to
Python a lot of times we complain about
the Python packaging problem but it
really is because python has been at the
leading edge of integrating lots of
different things together you look at
the syfy stack for example we're calling
out to fortran code or calling out to
see proceed code we're calling out to
native code from every stripe and so
we've kind of been at the forefront of
this fundamental general problem that
every language deals with including our
Ruby nodejs all of them do they all
don't they all sort of half solve it one
degree or another that the fundamental
tension is that production deployment
needs use a bit testability needs
testability needs reproducibility IT
managers want easy deployment won't be
able to test it understand how to back
back up to what they had before on the
other hand developers want agility and
easy development they want to be able to
use the latest package from the latest
greatest open-source piece that's come
out and they want to do that quickly and
so how do you kind of resolve this
challenge I see that I think that's the
fundamental challenge the face of
anybody trying to take advantage of open
source and I don't think you can take
advantage open source fully enough you
unless you address this so kind of the
fundamental principles complex things
things we've addressed all of this
deploy the systems you want to separate
everything out for development ease for
maintenance ease but when you actually
come to create an application it's
something that does something useful in
the world you have to bring it all back
together again and how you do that you
need a good package system and I and
that means you need good barb binary
artifacts a place to store them a place
to hold them a place to connect them a
place to deal with them and who needs
something this notion of multiple
environments that virtual M has
popularized in the Python ecosystem but
it's kind of a fundamental principle
that even operating system should really
get behind and are starting to get
behind you see from Red Hat the idea of
software collections emerging you see
other kind of packaging systems
promoting this idea of multiple
environments it's no longer I have a
system and I have one version of Python
installed or have one version of numpy
installed it's okay for this particular
application stack it needs these
dependencies and maybe there's a handful
of applications that use all those
dependencies all right so I want to talk
about how Conda actually is a really
helpful solution to a lot of these
problems and that with Khan as a base
you can do a lot of build a lot of great
systems and so all of this is free this
is all free stuff from the continuum we
like to give away free stuff we do have
to stay in business but I'm not going to
talk about how we do that here to talk
about the free stuff we give away Conda
is an open-source BST licensed package
manager it's free you can contribute
join the community help us make it
better it's on github it is a basic
cross-platform package manager like yum
or AB get it uses dependency management
there's it creates a system level
environment notion which is an
amplification of pythons virtual em to
actually system level so it's not just
it doesn't just mess with Python path in
order to set up your you know where it's
going to load modules from it actually
fundamentally deals on a system level we
have anaconda which is the full
distribution a lot of people just
download anaconda for a single click
install of a bunch of packages but it's
really a combination of what we call
mini condo which is Python plus Conda so
Python plus a package manager and then
from there you can do anything you want
you can build whatever dependency tree
you like including the Anaconda
distribution and then another one that's
actually not as well known because it's
all it's still in beta and we haven't
popularized it very much is something
called bin start org
Minister not org its purpose is to be a
package repository for everybody and if
you're willing to give your packages
away if you're willing to let people use
them and download them for free it's
completely free and it will always be
completely free if you're willing to
give your packages away so bin start on
org it integrates tightly with Conda so
you can easily release your binary
packages and make other people be able
to get your particular dependency set
all right we do have some premium
offerings here they're in the slide deck
i'm not going to go over them i guess
just maybe to help people understand
that we do we do we do give things away
for free and those are in a state giving
away for free and when there's no kind
of bait and switch seeing going on here
we kind of this is what we're selling if
you want those things great but this
stuff that's freezing to stay free so
Conda is one of those things it's
cross-platform and essentially what it
does it does for a cross-platform system
if you're just using Linux in your whole
environment is Linux then yum app gate
are pretty good they lack the
environment notion actually that Conda
has but for a lot of people when I was a
developer of numpy and scifi it was
interesting to watch kind of the
different platforms and kind of the
pressures that were there and I never
had complaints from linux users once
they once apt-get showed up and all of a
sudden is I go sure you can release new
version umpire I just use apt-get get
everything I need but the windows side
it was always a struggle because you
know people spend hours and days
building up their ecosystem they went oh
man a new release if I don't want a new
release I got it was a big problem
sekonda really solves X it provides the
same functionality as a nap ktorej yum
with the addition of environments across
platforms now when there are a few of
these package managers on Windows or not
as well-known things like chocolaty and
pack d and a few others exist so what
does kind of provide you it has
excellent support for system-level
environments in a lot of ways these are
like mini VMs you see a lot of the
energy around docker I oh you look oh I
could citing I can just virtualize a box
now if that box it's all you're doing is
creating a collection of files together
to work together kind of ironmans just
do that perp just just fine it's much
faster so there are really kind of the
Rope they can replace your usage of dr.
in many cases not there's just an
overlap of functionality there it
minimizes code copies I mean one
approach to that would be just a copy
Bowl trees over right and we do that if
we need to but where we were possible
uses link farms so hard links and soft
links depending on
exactly which is possible uses a
dependency solver one big difference one
big thing that's missing from the Python
from PI P I for example is a metadata
server but there's input the information
about dependencies you can't actually
know that on pi PI unless you traverse
and download all the packages so that
metadata server that tells you the
dependency graph is already available in
Conda and part of every kind of
repository and we use a dependency
solver in order to provide
satisfiability the format of a common
package is dirt simple it's very simple
so anybody can build one we have some
tools to build Conda packages but you
can build your own as well there's
nothing stopping you from just creating
your own it's just a tarball of the
binary that you're going to install and
then there's metadata that's easy to
allow static analysis it's easy to
create these idea of multiple channels
so you can actually have things coming
from both multiple things one big reason
people like anaconda is its user
installable Conda allows you to install
in your own directories your own private
installation of any environment you
don't have to get permission from
anybody to start and then the other
piece is you can use pip with Conda as
well we're not taking anything away you
can still use pip to install things that
if you don't have a kind of package for
it go to your environment just to pip
install if you want to basically source
build or else build from a package
that's available on pi PI and that works
just fine so here's a simple example
let's say I want to set up a test
environment cond update condo just make
sure you have the latest version of
Conda you don't have to write that
though I kind of create dash n kind of
create is the fundamental way to create
an environment dash n tells you to
create a named environment named
environments are stored in a particular
directory an environment is just a
directory on your path it's just a place
that's basically like / it's like the
prefix the main prefix for a change
route jail or something that creates a
peccary called a directory called test
somewhere but environment called test
and then I'm saying install Python and
pip into that directory so Conda is
actually general it's not spy thon
specific so when you create an
environment you have to tell it what you
want to install you could put our you
could put node you can put anything that
kind of package is available for so
Python pip make sure those are there and
then I want to know how do I use that
directory well how do i use the python
stored in that environment well i could
call it fully by expressing
powerpath but a common approach
especially on the command line is to use
this source activate notion of which
really changes your path just change
your path to make sure that bin
directory is on your is first on your
path on Windows the scripts a little bit
different now once i'm in that directory
you can see it's a little bit different
because of the test that's before my
little prefix now i want to install a
package that might be difficult to
install from source like scikit-learn
because I've have to download numpy and
scifi and it have to build and I don't
have a building have a build system on
my computer it's going to be a pain and
not that's basically the fundamental
complaint most people have besides maybe
the time it takes to do the build but
con install scikit-learn goes out and
grabs the binary package for your
platform installs it quickly easily and
you've got our working scikit-learn this
is true fried Python notebook this is
true for any of the four pandas any of
the things that people use now maybe I
want to create a different environment
right you can make create as many
environments as you like we have this
notion of environments or throw away
their free you can just have as many of
you want here's an example where I'm
actually creating a Python 3 environment
so Conda we it can be a little confusing
because kakani is based on Python but
I'm creating a Python 3 environment so
the way to think about this is your
building like like like a new language
you're building a new new bin directory
and put anything you want in there i'm
going to put python 3 in there so i put
python 3 in that new directory activate
it and then i can actually install
ipython notebook into that python 3 and
i can have an environment where i'm
testing out python 3 that's as simple to
switch between as every other
environment I have so it's it's really
easy to use kana to kind of go back and
forth in Python 3 and Python to it can
really help you kind of identify and
understand the differences or you can do
this all together and just you can have
a command line that's very very long if
it puts all the Packers you want to
install now you don't have to put every
package that will be installed because
the dependency analysis will grab all
the dependencies so you typically just
put the oh I'm Python I want ipython
notebook and then whatever it needs to
install those and those will all be
installed so an antic on installation is
really simple it's you have a root
installation and it has basically a
package cash / pkgs i'm going to go over
the slide into much detail basically at
the bottom you see it has a bin direct
3 has a Lib directory include all kind
of the basic user directories you might
have on Windows the path locations are a
little different you have a scripts
directory you still have a package cast
directory the package cash is where all
the you know the tarball is download and
then unzip basically untoward and that's
the package cash and then you have
environments just linked to it and so
it's a very straightforward approach to
building large-scale environments now if
we look at an actual kind of package we
see that it's just a bzip compressed tar
file and that's the extension at the end
the package name is everything you have
this package name which should have
anything in it and then you have this
version number and then a build string
which is not really used by Conda other
than perhaps the last integer which is a
build number the version and the package
name or what is used by Konnor to
resolve dependencies now if you look at
a kind of package it's just a unpacked
it's it's a packed our file of
everything if you were to take your
software and install it into a system
and then did a diff between the the disc
that you instead when it started then
when you installed it did a diff and
look at that that would be the kind of
package you'd have the full path to
everything up to the base of the prefix
reinstalled it so it's a lot like
basically everything in your system that
has different because I installed this
software and that's all zipped up
together or [ __ ] together in a single
package tar file and then zip be zipped
up and that's a pet chrono package so an
environment is exactly a union of all
those environments in fact if there if
Union file systems were more popular and
more common you just implement this as
by Union in all these little packages
together and that would be in an
environment environment is just a simple
Union file system of these individual
Conda package file systems now there's
one more thing a kind of package has
which is this info directory that's its
the metadata and there's only two
necessary pieces of metadata there's
others that can be there there's only
two that are really necessary one is the
files list just a mixing a manifest of
all the files that are installed and
then the other is an index JSON which
has dependency information it's pretty
lightweight only has little bit advanced
information so that's it everything l
in the condom pack is just whatever
happen to need to be installed maybe
stuff in man maybe stuff in bin include
lib share whatever now a big a big thing
I really love about Conda and I really
promote because i think it's an
incredible important idea is environment
and I relate it to the incredibly
important idea of name spaces in that
Tim Peters put in the Santa Python type
import this you see namespaces or one
honking gratia let's do more of those
environments have a similar feel there
one hungry idea I should isolate my
programming to a namespace to an
environment where I can be isolated from
everything else because that tends to be
a challenge you face when you're trying
to deke involve the workflows there's a
lot of useless there's just a few
reproducible science was the main
motivating use case that we had when we
created condo these environments I want
to be able to take something somebody's
done maybe have an ipod on notebook I
want to know all the packages they need
I wanna be able to reproduce that on
somebody else's system and have all the
specification needed so they can do that
very easily and with Conda that's
possible and it's how we it's how we do
it test eat is another big big use case
so a lot of you using Conda you have to
kind of remember kind of where things
are kind of info is sort of your basic
workhorse or give me information about k
where are my environment directories
where my package is stored how many do I
have you can get the named environments
you have with con info de and sometimes
if you're debugging particularly we love
it if you send us a message up that
includes kind of info dash dash all so
we can kind of see your setup in your
configuration to install a package we've
seen this it's very very simple con
install if you don't give it a named
environment a lot of times you'll see
just can't install something then it
goes the root environment and a lot of
people that's what they do this it's all
everything is the root environment that
works great it's good to know there's
the environments exist so you can go
beyond just everything in one big
environment so that's the dash n and
currently so in kata there's package
repositories you point to now will show
later how you can modify which
repositories it points to and create
your own repositories by default Conda
will point to the repositories that we
make freely available at reproduction
team do now how it works is these
repositories we call them channels so
channels are basically a big directory
of con
packages with a little bit of metadata
this metadata information about
dependencies of all those packages so
you can kind of just read the metadata
to infer what you have to download and
those channels when you do a conduct
command first thing it does is merge the
metadata from all your channels into one
big metadata so it knows okay these are
all the packages available to me I can
see or to get it and it uses that to go
grab the particular downloads if it
needs to perhaps you've already
downloaded doesn't need to download it
again so if you want to create your own
channel which is a very popular use case
because maybe you have your own software
you want to release and you want to kind
of use this same system there's two
options roughly that we've supported of
course you can do a lot of things
yourself as well but it's very easy for
option one just to create a directory of
condo packages that live somewhere big
directory of tar dot BZ files and then
run Conda index the common index command
on that directory will build that
metadata you know build is just as
metadata file that sits in that
directory and then you could either use
if you thought a system that that's on
your disk you can just use a file URL in
the Conda when you're specifying a
channel to Conda use file in your condo
our C files we'll see later or just use
a simple web server like simple HTTP
server on that directory and then you
have a condo channel you can point
people to it's very very simple to build
up a repository channel in Conda option
to if you don't want to set that up is
use bin start at org it's very easy to
do bin star upload of your package and
now it goes to a channel that you
constructed and there's a on premise
solution of that as well with an ax cut
with the Anaconda server so those are
two options to make channels so bin
start org is still in beta it should be
out of beta likely within a month it's
coming really close we're just trying to
make sure that it's a couple of the the
idea of a frozen channel is finalized
basically once you have a bin star
channel it's very easy to get one just
request an invite you know wait anywhere
from 30 minutes to eight hours depending
on who gets to it and and will pretty
much approve those invites Conda
installed see will allow you to tell it
a channel name and it will automatically
put the bin star user the bin star HTTP
in front if you would like to fully
specify your channel name because maybe
you have
running on some other web server you
constructed with kind of index you can
do that too and Conda will take that
channel as a place to look for prana
packages but it's very easy to integrate
with bin star kind of installed that CB
channel named package name and then it
can it will install from your package so
this is a very very easy way for you to
make software point people to it and
have them have a successful instant
download right it's it's it's really
really straightforward I'm really happy
about decks I feel like we've solved the
problem I feel like we've solved the
problem that's plagued me that's plagued
the entire side by community for a long
time and now there's a lot of you know
flexibility around that and I'm looking
forward to the kind of solutions that
will emerge that will it can use these
technologies now a lot of times when
you're using your kind of environment
you want to kind of see what's installed
see there's a kind of list command now
this command will also look at your
packages that weren't installed with
Conda maybe they were used maybe it was
Python set up about pie maybe it was pip
so it'll actually list those packages
well with Conda list and you'll see the
kind of the PIP instead of a build
number now quite often you want to
update you want to figure out where
you're going next it's very easy to say
content update pandas for example kind
of update scikit-learn it'll go download
the latest version install it in your
environment simple as that now there is
a caveat sometimes people will go ok I'm
going to Conda update anaconda that's
not the right way to update anaconda the
anaconda is a collection of packages
that are all tested to work together
it's what we call a meta package it's a
known stable release of all the versions
and so when you say con update anaconda
it will go to the latest anaconda meta
package right which is a collection of
specific versions of your other packages
so if you've gone in your environment
updated pandas updated scikit-learn from
the base anaconda and go back and say
can't update anaconda currently will
actually out go bill revert back to your
anaconda release so it's not often what
you want there is a command called Conda
update dash dash all and that will
actually go out and look for the latest
releases of everything in your
environment and try to download those so
there's a little bit of miscommunication
sometimes people kind of expect a
different use case it will keep working
on the usability there might be that we
were sort of raise an error or something
if if you have different things your
environment so you can search for a
package just looking for a cover reg ex
you have
I want to see you is there a package
that something like me own um you know
what are the num packages or what are
the the typo packages kind of search
typo you can actually add an outdated if
you want to look for only packages that
are installed but outdated currently
kind of that have new releases available
but but you don't have them you can also
do that with a searching you can remove
files so you can now removing is a
little bit different than you might
think because removing unlinked from
your environment but there may be other
environments on the system that are
using that package it doesn't delete the
files doesn't leave the files from your
file system just just your environment
no longer sees them that's what remove
does and you can give it a dash end for
the environment name as well as the
packages then you want to remove if you
actually do want to remove unused
packages then there's a kind of clean
dash T and a kind of clean Dash P
they'll remove the tarballs the cash tar
balls and then p will move all the
directories as well so at least
eliminate from your system from your
machine all the packages and then you
can remove an entire environment Connor
remove dash n dash dash all the you can
just delete all the directories you can
just look at a directory structure and
delete the whole thing the remove
command will actually run potentially
pre uninstall scripts that a package has
it might be that a package that's
installed might need to do some other
clean up that they've defined so the
desk remove will make sure that gets run
to rather than just deleting the file
maybe leave some state and some database
somewhere some registry somewhere the
package had to add a construct it's very
flexible what a kind of package can do
now another little use case four
continents that's pretty clever i think
and actually fairly useful is this idea
of i can go make an environment and then
kind of do whatever I want I can pythons
it up top I install I can pip install I
can kind of do what I want to build that
environment exactly i desire and then
i'll have a collection of untracked
packages kind of packaged as you will
show me this list of all the packages
that Connor doesn't know about that are
kind of apparently you installed them
without kind of tracking them now you
can if you if you use the kind of
package name and actually say give it a
package name give a package version
it'll take all those untracked packages
and build you a condo package that
contains all that information and allow
you to then ship that to somebody so
it's a ver
easy way to sort of do whatever you want
in your environment then reproduce that
by constructing a kind of package and
ship it off now just I kind of talked
about it as pickle 4 4 code in much the
same way pickle is a nice way to
serialize data that you're going to kind
of throw away and not really persist
forever pickle is not a good way to
persist a large data structures in the
same way this approach to counter
packaging is also it's a very nice way
to kind of send a reproducible
environment around for temporary uses
but a lot of time but it's not the best
way to sort of package Conda package do
you want to redistribute for a long time
because unless you're careful you have
to be careful to make sure that only the
package you're trying to package is in
there a lot of times for example if I
did pip install of a site kit learn
inside of a basic con environment then
it would go when it would download
socket learning with download sci fi 0
download numpy try to build all those
things now give me a large collection of
files and if I just said kind of package
it would I would create a single package
all that stuff it would not be separated
into the individual granular components
that it really should be so that's the
kind of thing you want to make sure
you're understanding the difference now
this kind of our C file we talked about
briefly in the past this is how you
configure we're kind of looks for
channels this how you can figure what
proxy servers if you need a proxy server
to go out to the Internet in your in
your location this is where you
configure where the environment
directories so these named environments
where is going to look for those you can
configure where those are you can
configure where your package cash is
when I download packages well where will
actually go and untie the directories
and there's various other things you can
you can set there's also a scripting
interface to this you can you can edit
the binary you can edit the text file if
you like or you can use the kind of
config command to add keys to that file
if you if you sort of want to script
this or a create an interface now like I
said Conda packages are a great way to
install your software and its really
nice to kind of have a community of
people using a similar way to install
complex software but you cannot but to
do that you really need we need people
to build packages so there's some neat
facilities and very useful facilities to
build new packages I mentioned the
format of at RBZ file is very simple and
as long as you construct a directory
tarde up and be easy to compress it with
an info directory for metadata
have a talk condo package you can do
that however you want you know feel free
to make whatever tool you want that does
that and builds it and condo will use it
just fine it doesn't it doesn't need to
be built by condo build or Conda pit
build but these are tools we've created
to make it easy so that you can for
example if you know oh I have this
there's this package on pipe I like
yesterday I saw the plan out talk for
example and plan out was a great new
tool it's on pi PI I said well wonder
how hard would be and basically within a
minute i had condo packages for plan out
and they're currently on my channel and
as i'll show you later actually there's
a convert utility because it has only
python code i can actually make a condo
package for every platform very easily
and they're all in my channel now and it
took about took about two minutes to do
the rest of that so it's very easy if
anything is available on pi p icon does
skeleton pi PI you give it the name of
the pie pie package and it will
construct a recipe directory for you now
you can go in and modify that recipe
recipe is just a directory with some
scripts but usually it's enough just to
just take that default recipe and condo
build the recipe directory and you get a
kind of package but one that's also
modified we can go and check make sure
the dependencies are right make sure
that its guests about what the
dependencies were kind of skeleton tries
to use the information that it can from
PI P is a little bit hard actually but
go and figure out the dependencies are
make sure you have those condo bill will
actually create a separate environment
and build everything in that separate
environment and then it will create
another environment to test everything
right to verify that what you're
building is relocatable it's not tied to
any specifical place where you've
installed it that's one of the things we
really try to promote with Conda while
you can have a kind of package that is
not relocatable you just are going to be
forced to install it into an environment
that's have a particular path like that
would be the case if you had did not
have a condom relocatable we really try
to promote relocatable packages is
that's the only way to take full of our
its full advantage of the environment
notion but I can just move these around
anywhere in my system now option two is
a recent addition there's a kind of pit
build so basically if pip can install it
Conda pitbull can pretty much usually
build a kind of package for it and all
this does it creates a separate
environment installs Python installs pip
and then pip install your package and
then takes essentially that package you
that untracked packages in your
environment bundles all that together
into a single download thanks
a little more clever than that because
it it tracks dependencies and if in a
pip tries to grab a dependency it'll
actually go out and separately build
that as a kind of package on its own
it's a little more intelligent than just
what I described but it's basically it
does something like that so recipes are
the key to building counter packages a
recipe is just a directory you have
build SH build about there's two files
there and the reason is because the popo
six like UNIX and Linux and Mac are so
different typically then your windows
recipes and so rather than have a big
fat one file with a big if statement in
it we just have two files build a bat
and build SH and then there's a ya moul
declarative file that describes the
dependencies describes the runtime
dependencies to build dependencies the
package name and optionally you can have
a run test py file that will be executed
during test phase just a file that when
when you build the package it'll execute
that make sure at baths passes there can
be patch files if you need to patch the
source for any reason and then any other
resources needed it can also be stored
in that directory here's an example of
recipe metadata now there's other
approaches this too we basically have an
approach where a metadata file can be a
template and it can be stored along just
sort of right next to the set up violent
we call automatically so you don't have
to kind of duplicate information in both
places if you have a Python file that
you're making but it's important to
remember that kind of packages are
bigger than Python Python packages they
can even package are and we have nascent
our packages for Linux 64 for examples
you can run our and install them in your
environment just like you can with
Python so we have this this general
approach to building recipes and it's
declarative approach now quite often
there's a lot of packages out there that
really just that are just Python files
or they're just text files there aren't
any really binaries in it on the other
hand we've built condo packages to be so
simple that they really have they can't
be really class cross-platform because
it's just a tarball of what's installed
in the file system so for example in the
windows system you have c colon you have
this different path structure you have
scripts instead of bin and so a pet
condo package even though it's consists
of just txt file
this text files are the same on both
package on both platforms you do have to
have a condom package for a different
platform this space is cheap so we went
that direction to make it simple to
build these things and simple to install
them so on top of that we created this
utility called Cana convert kada convert
will take a package that has any that
only has Python scripts in it or
basically has no binary to binary files
inside of it or at least Essos and dot P
Y Diez DLLs and it will convert it from
the package you are on to the package
you want this can run on any system so
my Mac system I could build the plan out
packages for windows 32 windows 64 Linux
32 Linux 64 it's really all it was the
metadata change and a file system
rewriting and then I can upload those to
the directory so this is a simple
command connect convert you give it a
directory it'll store in there give it
the top level directory and it'll store
win32 164 sub directories and then once
you have that kind of package there's a
simple bin star upload back the kind of
build command by default will ask you if
you want to upload a didn't bin star you
can turn that off in the condo RC file
save in star upload is false and so
don't do that but by default it makes it
very simple to build a package and make
it available to everybody and so if you
look at my you know bin start org slash
travis for example you'll see you know
several thousand packages I've been
playing with them not saying that all of
them are fantastic but I actually made
another account called auto or ever
doing some auto conversion I converted
about 18,000 of the pipe I packages to
condo packages on the auto account again
they're all beta they're not necessarily
well tested but they're automatically
built now once you have this repository
then Conda install dash C Travis you
don't have to put the full pathname you
just say dashti whatever the user name
is so in this so Conda install dash C
Travis package name and now Conda will
go to my to the bin star account of that
user to get the packages or add that
essentially to the con dar see file now
here's how you can use kana config
here's the particular keys you add if
you want to add a particular channel to
your so that every time you run Conda
you go to a particular channel Connie
config dash dash add channels this is
how you add travis's directory there's
another person Aaron mirror
it was built quite a lot of packages
especially for OS 10 pie cutie for
example is up there and then you can get
packages from other people other users
if you want to upload packages you first
register the package and then upload you
can actually just upload the package and
it'll go to some defaults it'll
basically become a personal package that
isn't that that you're sharing as we'll
see there's a couple of notions in bin
star there's three different notions of
visibility of packages on bin star
there's this idea of a of a private
package in a private package you're
gonna have to pay for if you want
private packages after the beta period
currently you get them for free but that
is what's going to does not necessarily
be free in the future personal packages
are public which anybody can see totally
free just fine that means this is your
kind of private this is my build then
there's the idea of a published package
the other the publish packages this is
kind of the package author or the
package maintainer or somebody who's
committing to create the binary for that
package should be publishing there so
that people can add that public channel
and that will be a default sort of known
quantity of where bin star of where good
kind of packages can live on bin star so
you can imagine personal kind of being a
wild west of people's individuals or
maybe it's somebody specific set of
packages that work for a specific thing
and then publish is like pie pie with
condo packages useful aliases not
necessarily needed an econo servers a
product we do sell but that's basically
the talk I'd like to thank the people
involved there have been elan schnell
principle condo developer currently an
econo developer ever if you're using
anaconda he's been building python
packages for a long time it's quite
expert at it actually it's a unique
skill if you're interested in building
python packages come talk to me we're
always looking for people who are good
at this because it sort of takes a lot
of nuances to figure out how to build on
Windows and Mac OS 10 all the rest Brian
Donovan who's currently author of
bouquet and principal contributor to
bouquet started the condo project
actually in one of the original authors
Shauna Ross Ross is the principal bin
start at org developer and then Aaron
mirror is a condo and Vince star
developer currently a continuum
there are other contributors as well to
the Conda resource I'd like that list to
grow longer so next time I give this
talk and I actually show a long list of
kind of contributors these are the folks
have started off all right I'll take any
questions at this point yeah let's start
in the front we have a microphone maybe
yeah the one place to go to get
tutorials and documentation on all this
kondaveeti org thank you can adapt I did
org the tutorial is actually growing
there's an FAQ now it's improving but it
could be better but it is improving and
then also kana dash H there is a quite a
bit of online help a lot of what I've
learned about Conda actually have
learned by just kana dash eh and
experimenting so it is it is helpful we
have the back in the back a couple of
questions first there what's the
interruption or the relationship between
a condo environments and the virtual
environments Python virtual environments
and the okay I'll take the next question
later later okay yeah there's separate
concepts so con environment so virtual
end is a it's a nice project that allows
you to kind of create Python virtual
environments continents are system level
so you can have an environment that has
are in it and it has an R view in it for
example or you can have a Python
environment has Python 3.3 right virtual
m doesn't let you kind of make a Python
3.3 environment inside of it it's sort
of just Python specific but kind of
abstractly they're similar conceptually
but implementation they're quite
different the way there did they're done
and that con is more general the second
one is there are no the Python wheels
packages which are a binary packages and
then a book secondo packages a similar
in concept may be so can you talk a
little bit about that yes there are some
overlap so with the wheels then you know
finally pip is getting closer to be able
to do the things that Connor can already
do I guess so it initially think it's a
good question if people want to make
wheels that's fine you can make connor
package from wheels as well they're
different like if you'll talk to our
condo developers they'll say one thing I
think the condo Packers formats quite as
simpler easier
build them than it is to build wheels
but wheels for example there's a bee
disc wheel inside of a Python set up a
pie there's a way to do that so I think
it's sort of generally good to have them
I like the fact we have more binaries
available and I talked to Nick Coughlin
all the time we were at PyCon recently
just talking about kind of what's the
difference in the way Nick describes it
is he considers Connor to be an
integrators tool but if you're using pip
including wheels including the the pit
package of source packages on pi PI you
are an integrator like you are a self
integrator at that point Conda is a is a
solution to handle the integration for
you right so you know I would say but
without wheels cana solves is the only
thing to solve that problem with wheel
wheels kind of solve the problem a
little bit but they're missing the
metadata still the metadata to point o
is what kind of what they're moving
towards and you know so that's that's my
perspective on it you know I think
wheels a little bit redundant at this
point I don't think they're necessary
but you know they have some momentum and
people like you know there's ways to
build them and that's fine and so
they'll exist and will make cotton
packages out of them very simply I guess
yeah I I recently ran into a problem
trying to pip install a package that
depended on openssl which was installed
by Conda is that a limitation of Conda
that you you can if you have a Python
package that depends on a sea library
installed by Conda that that can only be
installed by condo no I don't do work
yeah let me know let's file an issue
about that it's not lit shouldn't be a
limitation but you know there's always
surprises that show up right that's not
it that's not intentional it shouldn't
be that way yeah we've told Aaron about
it ok great ya know I I'm not I'm not
clear why that would be it shouldn't be
the case right unless maybe there's
something that pips looking for
specifically that we're not aware of yet
it ended up having to do with like
relative paths in the sea libraries that
Conda had installed and and we had to
set you know like a dynamic library path
in order for the binaries to see those
and it just didn't seem like a very good
solution
it could be so for example it could be
that there are some for example Python
package that pip uses the set up I might
be looking for certain see libraries in
a very specific user directory like
quite like this notion of relocatable
binary is a powerful one but not
everybody sort of is is cooperating
there right so you know I've seen a lot
of recipes for example that have very
hard coded I'm going to look in user lib
something if I'm on Linux for the
openssl library yeah it definitely
wasn't that okay it is kind of a dynamic
library lookup problem and it appears to
be definitely related to the way Conda
had installed open SSL in this situation
ok ok it's Connor doesn't actually all
it tries to do is make it relocatable so
just actually rather than use an LD
library path it uses relative paths so
but definitely we should look at it but
you know again this notion relocatable
is kind of a new concept it I think it's
a valuable concept but it's not familiar
too and it's not common the way people
typically build and so yeah there's a
lot of interactions like that that could
exist but it should not be the case
those should be all be resolvable so
thank you for bringing to our attention
when they come up so building on the
concept of being Mormon environment
manager and not just a package manager
yeah what are the facilities or plans to
allow well I don't just want to get you
know numpy 18 I want I want I want to be
able to do Conda install my package from
my master branch on my github repo ah
right yes no that's a good point that's
a good question essentially you want to
do the bill is that the challenges you
want to essentially create a package
from the git repo and then install that
kind of all in one fell swoop but I
don't want to go do the manual packet
recreation stuff so I would so basically
a tool like the kind of build command
could should be able to accept to the
URL yeah I would say that's a feature we
can add to a kind of build one thing
we've done actually is to stabilize
Conda itself is separated out so just
like it when you say get and then give
it a sub command it'll actually look for
a get dash so if you try to get log for
example and look for get dash log as a
binary we do that with Conda as well so
Conda bill
actually runs kata dash build and that's
a separate package now so kana dash
billa's own package you can install
separately so things like this I could I
mean I would love to see you know better
tools for in a great good integration
right now we have internal developers we
use kana internally for everything and
so we zip for deployment for releasing
we've we've cut ourselves on a lot of
the corner cases now and you know I'm
sure that all that we've been trying to
kind of make it more and more robust and
that use case has come up and we've sort
of working around it currently with it
with sort of hard coded things but I
would love to see the tool like that all
right well I cut it thank you so it's a
fascinating conversation build systems
are at the core of all of our
frustrations let's go Travis 10 round of
applause thank you and we'll have James
Powell here in a few minutes